president zielinski of ukraine will be
addressing the united nations security
council today about the horrific events
in bucha he visited the city yesterday
taking his first known trip outside of
kiev since the russian invasion began
his goal is to bring attention to the
violence he's calling genocide nancy
cordes is at the white house where u.s
officials haven't gone quite that far
nancy how does the biden administration
plan to respond
well nate the white house is vowing to
issue new sanctions against russia this
week it comes as we're learning that
european nations are planning to phase
out the use of russian coal ships and
trucks and now president biden is
calling for a war crimes trial for
vladimir putin
this guy is brutal and what's happening
in bucca is outrageous and everyone's
seen it the horrifying death toll in
bucha is prompting international
consensus
from germany to poland to the uk world
leaders are no longer reluctant to label
vladimir putin a war criminal the images
that we saw coming out of butcher over
the weekend were harrowing appalling
probable evidence of war crimes and
possibly a genocide but when and how
russian leader vladimir putin would be
held accountable
those are questions without answers
right now we should follow him to the
ends of earth to prosecute him on monday
france and germany did expel about 75
russian diplomats calling them
undesirables in spain u.s law
enforcement agents seized a 90 million
dollar yacht owned by russian
billionaire victor vekelberg it's the
first such seizure by the u.s
but u.s officials stopped short of
declaring the bucha massacre evidence of
genocide we have seen atrocities we have
seen war crimes we have not yet seen
a level of systematic
deprivation of life
of the ukrainian people to rise to level
of genocide the national security
advisor warned that russia's withdrawal
of ground troops near kyiv does not mean
an end to the bloodshed is near russia
still has forces available to outnumber
ukraine and russia is now concentrating
its military power on fewer lines of
attack
despite all of this russia is still
somehow a member of un's human rights
council but that's something that u.n
diplomats believe they can change today
they would need to have the votes of
two-thirds of member countries to strip
russia of its membership and they're
going to hold a vote later today gail
nancy we thank you